people say okay what about this speech
and what about this speech and then my
question to those people always is okay
well then who would you like to see
making that decision it drove me nuts
throughout the entire Trump presidency
how many people would call for hate
speech laws but then also say that Trump
is literally Hitler so how can you have
those two views at the same time so you
want the government to be controlling
speech the same government that you
yourself just said you think the
figurehead or you know the head of the
Executive Branch is literally Hitler and
you don't see how those two don't make
sense together if anything the people
who really hated Trump had thought he
was Hitler should have came out of that
presidency more free more for Free
Speech but that's just not how it worked
out